was ist das für ein wahnsinn dank euch
ist mein buch tesla oder wie du machst
die elektromobilität revolutioniert ein
spiegel bestseller war diese woche auf
platz 19 haarscharf eingestiegen und
damit sind wir mitten im thema denn
unter meinem post hier gestern unter dem
community tab hat ingo stefan nach einem
video gefragt was mal verbrenner mit
elektroautos vergleich nichts leichter
als das denn genau darum dreht es sich
auch in meinem buch und das ergebnis des
vergleichs ist verblüffend eindeutig
spoiler alarm elektroautos sind
tatsächlich preiswerter als verbrenner
bot im video mache ich die rechnung auf
jetzt also punkt für punkt der vergleich
verbrenner gegen elektroauto klicks
umsatz im future gibt es dreimal pro
woche spannende science videos abonniert
den kanal und aktivierte glocke nur so
verpasst ihr nichts los geht's
herzlich willkommen diesen vergleich
mache ich natürlich gerne und fange
direkt mal mit einem zitat von volker
quaschning an professor für erneuerbare
energien und mitbegründer von scientists
for future zum einhalten unser
klimaschutzziele brauchen wir weniger
autos die schon in weniger als zwanzig
jahren alle ausschließlich elektrisch
unterwegs sein müssen im buch von
christoph krachten wird das mit
eindrucksvollen fakten sehr anschaulich
untermauert das buch bekommt ihr
übrigens direkt hier und ami und zwar
exklusiv von mir signiert noch bis zum
dreißigsten achten könnt ihr es
bestellen danach mache ich erstmal zehn
tage urlaub videos gibt es dann weiter
aber keine signierten büchern wenn man
elektroautos nicht aus der sicht von
verbrennern sieht sondern umgekehrt an
die betrachtung herangeht öffnet das
einem die augen tun wir also mal so als
würden elektroautos das verkehrsmittel
sein dass alle für den individualverkehr
nutzen und jetzt möchte jemand pkw mit
verbrennungsmotoren einführen ich stelle
mal die vielleicht steile these auf die
würden gar nicht zugelassen weil sie zu
dreckig und zu gefährlich sind die frage
ist also was würde jetzt alles
schlechter werden aus der sicht von
elektroautos um es vorwegzunehmen auch
unabhängig von der co2 belastung sind
elektroautos einfach technisch die
überlegene konstruktion verbrenner sind
nämlich sehr fehlerbehafteten
fortbewegungsmittel die dazu noch extrem
gefährlich sind da werden hoch brennbare
flüssigkeiten dem fahrzeug transportiert
und dann noch zum brennen gebracht bzw
schlimmer noch zum explodieren das ist
eine extrem komplizierte und anfällige
technik die dazu eben auch gefährlich
ist
fahrzeugbrände bei einem unfall geraten
sie schneller als e autos in brand was
zudem immer wieder passiert elektroautos
hatten wir müssen auch bei ihren
batterien diesen konstruktionsbedingten
nachteil der inzwischen durch die
thermische trennung der zellen behoben
ist stand der technik ist dass sie
gegenseitig isoliert werden wenn sie
überhitzen sie sind nun von zwei
schichten isolationsmaterial umschlossen
die beide bei hitze auf quellen und zum
einen die batterie umschließen und zum
anderen die zellen voneinander trennen
bei diesel und benzinmotoren hat bisher
noch niemand eine möglichkeit gefunden
brände so effizient zu unterdrücken
batterien können jetzt nur noch brennen
wenn sie beschädigt werden was tesla zum
beispiel mit einer titanplatte
verhindert die alles zerschmettert was
sich den batterien von unten nähert
verbrenner autos brennen also nach der
bisherigen datenlage deutlich öfter der
faktor beträgt ungefähr je nach studie
10 bis 45 dass es wissenschaftlich
belegt und gilt im schnitt auf die
gefahrene strecke dass es weniger
elektroautos gibt es dabei also
berücksichtigt warum lesen wir denn dann
so viel über elektroauto brände ganz
einfach brennende pkw sind nichts
besonderes niemand schreibt darüber
außer es sind elektroautos münster
skurriler fall in den usa ein brennendes
modell y am ende kam heraus zuerst
geriet ein aus neben dem fahrzeug in
brand dann erst brannte der tesla dazu
kommen noch zwei wirklich ernste
sicherheitsrelevante nachteile
verbrenner sind instabiler als
elektroautos während im elektroauto das
schwerste teil die batterie ist und im
boden sitzt sind es bei einem verbrenner
motor getriebe und tank und die sitzen
so hoch und sind so schlecht verteilt
dass sie das fahrzeug instabil machen
der schwerpunkt liegt zu hoch weshalb
sich verbrenner autos viel leichter
überschlagen können ein model s von
tesla ist das in sicherheitstests bisher
nicht gelungen die batterie verhinderte
das überschlagen der schwerpunkt ist
dafür einfach zu niedrig die straßenlage
eines verbrechers ist mit der eines
elektroautos kaum zu vergleichen sie ist
durch die schlechte verteilung der
gewichte deutlich unsicherer diese
fahrzeuge können ins schleudern geraten
oder ganz von der fahrbahn abkommen was
nicht selten passiert der audi tt und
die mercedes a klasse mussten
nachträglich modifiziert werden damit
das nicht so oft geschieht bei
elektroautos ist das alles kaum oder nur
schwer möglich jetzt kommen ingenieure
und bringen als gutes beispiel fahrzeuge
mit mittelmotor ok erstens sind die
immer noch schlechter weil eben kein
motor soll tief jahr an der batterie
eingebaut werden kann und getriebe und
tank bleiben ja noch
verbrenner sind bei unfällen
gefährlicher
zudem haben elektroautos eine deutlich
verbesserte knautschzone der motor vorne
fehlt und so drückt beim unfall kein
riesiger heißer klotz in den
fahrgastraum verbrenner sind bei der
wartung bis zu zehnmal teurer dazu
bedeutet die technik der
verbrennungsmotoren einen erheblichen
wartungsaufwand ölwechsel riemen und
ketten die gewartet und ersetzt werden
müssen ein verbrennungsmotor hat rund
zehn mal mehr teile als ein elektromotor
und die meisten davon bewegen sich mit
einem minimalen spielt das unbedingt
stimmen muss deshalb verschleißen
verbrennungsmotoren deutlich schneller
als elektromotoren elektromotor sind
weitgehend wartungsfrei wie überhaupt
elektroautos kaum service benötigen
viele teile neben dem motor gibt es gar
nicht oder sie werden viel weniger
gebraucht keine kupplung nur ein
einfaches getriebe keine caravelle bei
hinterradantrieb weder anlasser oder
auspuffanlage noch katalysator und so
weiter und so fort und keine 80 bis 100
steuergeräte wie es sie in jedem
verbrenner gibt um zum beispiel
klimaanlage abs und airbags zu steuern
bei tesla fahrzeugen gibt es deutlich
weniger davon und das meiste wird von
einem zentralrechner gesteuert zudem
halten die bremsen rund
300.000 kilometer weil meistens mit den
elektromotoren gebremst wird die dann
als generatoren genutzt werden und die
energie in die batterie ehre kooperieren
wie die rückgewinnung der bremsenergie
genannt wird bei verbrennen müssen die
bremsbeläge nach spätestens 50.000
kilometern gewechselt werden und später
dann auf den bremsscheiben was zudem mit
erheblichen kosten verbunden ist während
fahrzeuge mit verbrennungsmotoren
regelmäßig gewartet werden müssen und
bei ihnen ab etwa 100.000 km deutlich
mehr reparaturen anstehen entfällt
vieles davon komplett bei
elektroantrieben teslas haben zum
beispiel gar keine wartungsintervalle
sie werden durch die software in die
werkstatt geholt wenn es nötig ist
sprich die software meldet sich mit
einer nachricht und fordert dazu auf
einen werkstatt termin zu vereinbaren
tesla extrem fahrer hans jörg eberhard
freiherr von gemmingen enorm berg der
mit seinem model es inzwischen mehr als
eine million kilometer zurückgelegt hat
gibt die wartungskosten mit 1300 euro
auf 100000 kilometer an inklusive der
reifen laut adac liegen sie bei einem
fahrzeug mit verbrennungsmotor bei einer
laufleistung von 15.000 kilometern im
jahr bei 60 bis etwa 200 euro im monat
bei 15.000 kilometern kommen wir also
wenn wir im schnitt von 150 euro
ausgeben bei einem fahrzeug in der
klasse des model s auf 1800 euro pro
jahr das sind auf 100000 kilometer
12.000 euro fast das zehnfache auf eine
million kilometer sind es 120 tausend
euro wobei beim verbrenner noch zwei
neuanschaffungen dazukommen dürften das
heißt für eine million kilometer in der
model s fahrzeugklasse müssen beim
verbrenner geschätzten 300.000 euro für
die anschaffung ausgegeben werden plus
wartungskosten von 120.000 euro
gesamtpreis
420.000 euro bei model s sind es
inklusive wartung zwischen 100 und 160
tausend euro also ein drittel bis die
hälfte der kosten verbrenner sind
ineffizient hinzu kommt die desaströse
effizienz von verbrennungsmotoren
lediglich 25 prozent der energie werden
in antriebskraft umgesetzt 75 prozent in
wärme während ein model s zum beispiel
rund 20 kilowattstunden auf 100
kilometern verbraucht was an benzin
äquivalent von 2,3 litern entspricht
liegt dieser energieverbrauch beim
fahrzeug mit verbrennungsmotor in
derselben klasse mit prospekt daten beim
dreifachen die effizienz von
elektroautos beträgt eben knapp 90
prozent und das betrachtet nur die
verluste im fahrzeug beim verbrenner
kommen noch verluste durch förderung
transport raffinierung und verteilung
hinzu beim elektroauto das fast
ausschließlich über die ladenetz mit
regenerativen energien versorgt wird
kommen lediglich der verbrauch bei der
herstellung der anlagen der transport
über strom leitung und der lade verlust
baron strömen dazu aber so oder so
elektroautos schneiden grundsätzlich
besser ab auch wenn man den co2 rucksack
berücksichtigt herr brenner verpesten
die umwelt dann stoßen
verbrennungsmotoren auch noch umwelt
schädliche abgase aus und das tun sie
nicht etwa wie industrieanlagen durch
hohe schornsteine so dass menschen nicht
direkt geschädigt werden sie geben sie
genau dort ab wo sie fahren und sich
auch personen zu fuß bewegen oder mit
dem fahrrad das verrückte die personen
atmen die abgase dann direkt ein und in
der folge schädigen stickoxide und
feinstaub ihre gesundheit dazu kommt
noch deutlich mehr feinstaub durch die
bremsen die bei verbrennern viel öfter
betätigt werden müssen als bei
elektroautos und neben dem co2 ausstoß
der dazu führt dass wir selbst hier in
deutschland inzwischen im sommer
lebensgefährliche temperaturen erreichen
machen all diese eigenschaften nach
menschlichem ermessen doch eigentlich
verbrenner nicht zulassungsfähig der
verbrennungsmotor gehört zum alten eisen
es gibt also sehr gute gründe warum der
verbrennungsmotor im wahrsten sinne des
wortes zum alten eisen gehört in
kalifornien der fünf größten wirtschaft
weltweit wenn kalifornien das land wäre
wird der verkauf von pkw mit
verbrennungsmotor ab 2035 verboten dort
dürfen also noch 14 jahre lang
verbrenner verkauft werden dann ist
schluss auch in der eu wird über ein
ende 2035 diskutiert und andere länder
werden folgen der verbrennungsmotor ist
ein auslaufmodell an dem die deutsche
industrie viel zu lange festgehalten hat
was er jetzt große probleme bereiten
werden bmw ist mit dem i3 und dem i8 mit
werf gestartet hat aber dann wieder die
elektromobilität ausgebremst der
volkswagen konzern hat das steuer
endlich herumgerissen und auch
zulieferer wie zf bosch und continental
haben elektroantriebe ganz oben auf ihre
agenda der rest dümpelt noch etwas träge
und uninspiriert vor sich hin alles in
allem ist die deutsche autoindustrie
aber zu spät dran und eigentlich waren
die entwicklung und der vormarsch des
elektroantriebs vorhersehbar aber es ist
wie immer die alte technik wird so lange
bevorzugt wie sie bessere erträge
abwirft das ist aber immer zu lange denn
schon vorher beginnt der wandel der erst
reagiert wenn eine technologie sich
schon durchgesetzt hat wird es sehr
schwer haben fossile energieträger
werden massiv subventioniert und was
nicht vergessen werden sollte die
fossilen energie träger überleben nur
dank massiver subventionen je nach
berechnungen sind das 550 milliarden bis
5 billionen dollar pro jahr auf der welt
so rechnet nämlich der internationale
währungsfonds der auch die schäden an
der umwelt mit einberechnet wenn auch
ein wert für die subventionierung von
erneuerbaren energien nur schwer zu
berechnen ist er liegt in jedem fall
sehr sehr deutlich darunter aber um den
fokus noch mal auf einen anderen
wichtigen punkt zu denken wir brauchen
auch unbedingt weniger mobilität wie es
volker quaschning schon am anfang sagte
wir müssen vor allem weniger fahren
insgesamt müssen wir die mobilität
verringern weniger unterwegs sein mehr
aus dem homeoffice erledigen und vor
allem weniger fliegen unsere mobilität
muss sich grundsätzlich ändern ansonsten
werden wir hier auf dem planeten
gegrillt jedes gramm co2 zählt und jeder
und jeder sollte kritisch überprüfen wo
schon jetzt deutlich gespart werden kann
eine urlaubsreise mit dem elektroauto
ist deshalb schon heute für das klima
die schonendste art in die ferne zu
reisen mehr dazu gibt es hier in meinem
buch meinem spiegel bestseller nur unter
diesem link auch von mir signiert
einfach draufklicken und im nu war an de
shop auf amazon bestellen danke fürs
lesen und danke für eure unterstützung
bis dann bleib dran